John welcome to Dave Ramsey show how are
you doing Dave better than I deserve
what's up in your world sir okay so I
have myself a little bit of situation
basically have a joint bank account with
my parents that I got back when I was 18
and they are not very good with their
money I just got a new job doing AC work
making pretty good money depending on
how busy we are right now we're in our
slow season and they keep having
overdress from their counseling I'm an
overdraft protection for them and so
they ended up pulling a quite a good
chunk of money out of my bank account
and I told them hey I can't afford
another overdraft on our okay well we've
got it mitt there was another overdraft
sure recently and I told them hey I need
that money all over you I'm 22 years old
okay we'll just we'll go open a checking
account okay and close it and close that
one take your name off of that one okay
and and put your check put your checks
in your account your grown man okay
what's the purpose you having what's the
purpose of having a joint account
especially in a toxic situation well
basically I don't get a service charge
for having an account under under my
dad's account
yeah well whoopee it's time to bid
growing up you got a service charge you
got a first the price of a service
charge you get control of your life okay
it feels kind of good really feels kind
of good and make sure you go at the same
Bank you go by and you close your name
off of that account so I want my name
off of this account that way you're not
responsible for their future overdrafts
because they're going to screw up your
credit and you're legally responsible
when your name is on an account for
overdress so you need to get your name
off of that account and you need to open
your own account okay and then one of my
savings accounts I've got two of them
open one for my car savings and they
have learned there is their name on
those as well yes yes and they're my
pants are benefactors
do i but there it's separated from there
so I meant stop stop stop stop stop stop
hold on is that are they a joint owner
on the checking account
are they the beneficiary if you die
there's a dirt they are their joint
account basically he has access to to my
money if you needed to pull out money
from from my account he could yeah stop
you need to go close all those accounts
to okay because they're mishandling
money but John your money's going to
disappear honey okay and you'll have to
be mean to him or nasty to them you just
say mom and dad I talked to a financial
coach and he says that he told me that
I'm 22 years old it's time for me to
establish my own financial identity so
I'm going to move all of these accounts
I'm going to take my name off of any of
the accounts that have our name on it
and I'm going to close our close out my
savings and move it into my name and a
thank you for your help mom and dad up
to this point though I appreciate it and
it's time for me to be a man and move on
okay
just be kind but now but be very firm if
they if they insist that you keep the
their name on the accounts just smile
and say no I can't do that okay and
they'll be cooperative but I don't care
if their cooperative hurt I don't care
if they're cooperative the only question
is how bad their feelings will be hurt
but I think when you catch it you say
thank you for helping me get to where I
am but now it's time at 22 years old for
me to be a man and for me to have this
stuff in my name and us to separate
things and you don't have to go into you
people are awful with money you're
telling me you don't do that that's not
what you do okay okay that's really
tempting but you're not going to do any
of that but John listen if you don't
follow my advice it's going to cost you
everything in those accounts okay and it
may cost you your relationship with your
parents because you're eventually going
to get so sick and tired of them ripping
off your money that you're going to lose
it eventually eventually you know and so
it while you still can
while there's still some money there and
but before the damage is permanent to
you you need to move away so you can be
gentle and kind because if you wait till
later it's going to be nasty
and it's not going to be a healthy
situation so please please please this
week move the stuff into your name and
then gently and kindly thank them for
the help to this point and just blame it
on you wanting to be your own man at 22
I felt like that I needed to stand up I
know dad you would have done this when
you were my age and that kind of stand
that's kind of statement you say right
yes
definitely let me just tell you my son
is 23 I have my name on nothing of his
and he does pretty well
big probably be pretty cool if he put my
name on actually because I could get
some of his money because he's doing
pretty good but I'm say it's a part of
your emotional break from your parents
as a part of your emotional manhood
womanhood for you ladies out there it's
really good for you too legally in this
sense move out of your parents basement
you know and get control of your own
life it's a good good thing